وفي اخر التطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا تستمر المعارك بين الجيشين
الروسي والاوكراني على الجبهتين الجنوبيه
والشرقيه اذا تحدثت سلطات المهنيه لروسيا
عن قصف الاوكرانيين في دونيتك ولوجان
واشارت الى حشود لمدرعات اوكرانيه على
محور رخيصه بينما كشفت وسائل الاعلام
الروسيه تمركز قوات فاجنر مدينه البخ
وتحديدا واعلنت سلطات لوجان لروسيا انا
مدنيا واحدا على الاقل قتل صباح اليوم في
قصف صاروخيا اوكرانيا على بلده سخانوف
غربي
باربع صواريخ من طراز همارس كما قصفت
مدينه
المجاوره في ثلاثه صواريخ من الطراز نفسه
اذا المعارك اشتدت في مختلف المحاور
والجبهات خصوصا في الجبهتين الشرقيه
والجنوبيه
اذا تستخدم مختلف انواع الاسلحه الثقيله
فيها لاسيه ماء المدفعيه والدبابات
وراجمات الصواريخ خصوصا في محور خيرسون اذ
تحشد القوات الاوكرانيه عددا كبيرا من
الدبابات والعربات والمدرعات استعدادا
لشنه هجوم مضاد وقالت وسائل الاعلام
الروسيه الى قوات بادنر اصبحت على بعد
كيلو مترين فقط من فخمه حيث تخوض اشتباكات
مع القوه الاوكرانيه اما في الجبهه
الشرقيه
فانت القوات الاوكرانيه المناطق الواقعه
تحت السيطره الروسيه قصفتها في اقليم دون
بس في مقاطعه لوغانسك ودونيستك
اعلنا من جانبه نائب وحاكم مقاطعه خرسون
الموالي لروسيا جرين ستريموسوف انا القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه تحشد دبابات وعربات
مدرعه باعداد كبيره على محور يخرسون وقال
ستريموس اوف ذا في منشور على قناته على
تليجرام ان القوات الاوكرانيه تحشد قوه
كبيره عند ضواحي مقاطعه
بينها اعداد ضخمه من المعدات ومن المركبات
المدرعه والدبابات كذلك